everyone is wondering is why.
Why?
Hopefully they'll get to the
bottom of it.
Thank you very much.
>>> Look at this picture that we
have from the Michigan state
campus in the hours after the
shooting.
You can see that young man there
highlighted on the right side of
the screen.
He is wearing an oxford strong
sweatshirt.
Oxford, that's in reference to
high school.
That is near Detroit.
As many of you know, a gunman
killed four students and wounded
seven other people just 15
months ago.
That student says he got the
t-shirt at a fund-raiser but
underscores the reality that she
is referencing there that some
of the people, some of the
students survived not one but
two mass shootings.
>> For me, the most haunting
picture of last night was
watching the cameras pan through
the crowds and seeing a young
person wearing an oxford strong
sweatshirt.
The sweatshirts handed out after
those kids lived through a
school shooting 15 months ago.
And we have children in Michigan
who are living through their
second school shooting in under
a year and a half.
>> Joining us now is one of
those students, a student
traumatized by the mass
shootings at Michigan state and
at her high school, oxford high
school, Eva Ferguson.
I'm so glad you're here with us
this morning.
You're so young.
You're my little brother's age.
He's a freshman in college.
And I know you had been --
oxford high school was your high
school.
You've been on this campus for
weeks and now another shooting
has happened.
What was going through your
mind?
>> I was flabbergasted to say
the least.
After oxford, they said that
this wasn't going to happen
again.
We were going to be safe going
back to school.
And that's just not the case.
The other night I was in shock.
I didn't think it was real,
honestly.
>> Did you know any of the
victims?
>> At oxford, I did nomad I son
-- know Madison but at msu I
didn't know any of them.
>> Were there similarities to
how you were alerted?
Did you get anything from the
school?
Was there a mass alert or
anything that went out?
>> There was an e-mail that went
out to a lot of the students who
had signed up for the safe msu
app.
>> Eva, what is it like to be on
campus, to have to call your
parents again to talk about the
message that's you're getting
from officials, what you're
seeing on social media and
hearing from friends about the
cop cars that were on campus?
>> It was like traumatizing all
over again.
At the time we didn't know
information.
I didn't know where the shooter
was.
I thought I was in imminent
danger.
Yeah.
It was horrifying.
>> You are going to see someone?
-- Are you going to see someone?
>> Pardon?
>> Are you going to see someone
or talk to someone like a
counsellor?
>> Yeah.
After oxford I was going to a
therapist for a while.
And then I stopped.
But right now I actually am
seeing a therapist.
>> You are.
Listen, this is what the text
message from the school said.
The protocol, I think is run,
hide, and fight.
What do you think of that
guidance?
There were people in a classroom
and someone knocking on the
door.
They didn't know if it was
police or not.
What do you think of the
guidance you got and getting
from these -- in these
situations?
>> I think that those are
very -- like -- what's the word?
Understandable, good things you
should be doing.
It's important to not shut down
and to save yourself.
And to fight for everyone around
you and not let someone like
that get what they want
essentially.
>> I just want to talk about how
amazing you are and what you've
been through.
Not only did you have the
shooting at your high school and
you just experienced this one at
Michigan state, you're also a
cancer survivor.
You had only been at campus a
few weeks.
This is supposed to be one of
the most exciting times in your
life, you're going to college.
You have this big moment.
You accomplished that.
Do you feel like the system
failed you given that this
happened to you twice?
>> 100%.
There should have been laws made
years ago when sandy hook
happened and it never did.
I feel like now's the time
people need to start realizing
there is people dying every day
because of gun violence.
And something needs to be done
about it.
>> Absolutely.
Eva, you are really brave.
We're really glad you came on to
talk about this.
You're right, it's unfair you've
gone through this and no one
your age should have to go
through this.
No one should.
We're very glad you came on to
talk about it though.
>> Thank you for having me.
>> Thank you.
Not once but twice.
And she's not the only one.
There are others who have gone
through it more than once.
Look, I can't imagine what I
would do in this situation.
We were asking each other if
you -- would you open the door
if there was a knock and they
said it is police, let me in.
I don't think I would trust.
That even though they may there
be to save me.
I don't know.
I can't imagine being in that
situation.
>> She's so young.
My little brother just turned
19.
>> Do they talk about it?
>> It's just what they've grown
up with.
And they do get that training.
The fact she's been through it
before.
But to hear her dad talking to
Allison last night and saying we
just couldn't believe that you